PT's voted to simplify labeling of  household appliances by the end of 2019  only seven categories from A to G will  remain to identify the most  energy-efficient products the European  Union is celebrating 30 years of Erasmus  this year 9 million students as well as  volunteers and trainees have benefited  from this European exchange program 28  countries of the European Union  including the United Kingdom will host  the European capitals of culture between  2020 and 2030 3 to promote cultural  richness and diversity women get around  40% less pension than men MEP s are  calling for measures to reduce and  prevent this inequality so reduce  inequalities in Europe EU lawmakers say  subsidies allocated to Member States  post-2020 should be more adequate and  simplified